hi everybody happy Tuesday hope you're
having a great day welcome to today's
posit Enterprise Community Meetup
over the past few months we've featured
a number of stories from amazing
pharmaceutical leaders at rash
AstraZeneca GSK Eli Lilly Pfizer Jansen
all sharing their perspectives on the
adoption of Open Source
one of the common questions that I've
seen across many of these meetups
webinars and data science Hangouts is
how teams are training the next group of
users and questions about best practices
for those learning
I'm so happy to have Garrett girlmann
our director of learning at posit
joining us for today's presentation
Garrett is an award-winning R instructor
the author of Hands-On programming with
r and co-author of the best seller are
for data science
I also wanted to say thank you to Devin
Pastor one of our principal Solutions
Engineers who works with a lot of our
Pharma customers at posit who is helping
out in the background will also join us
for the Q a
you may see Devin answering a few
questions in the YouTube chat as well
so with that you can use YouTube for
questions but you can also ask
anonymously through the slido link that
I'll pull up on the screen here as well
and we'll copy that over into the the
chat too
but with that thank you all so much for
deciding to spend some time with us and
I will pull Garrett up on stage here
with me and turn it over to you
all right thank you Rachel can people
see what what we want them to see looks
great
I can see that you can see your uh title
Presentation and I'm gonna jump
backstage
hello everybody as Rachel said my name
is Garrett I am the director of learning
at posit but I've been working with
posit formerly known as our studio for
about a decade mostly teaching people
how to use R to write code to do data
science
and the other things that you do with
art and now more and more python 2.
many of the clients that I've worked
with were people who are trying to
migrate from SAS to r or from XL to r or
you might just say nothing to R so
they're trying to train teens to learn
how to code do reproducible work
and to do program assisted data science
and what I discovered is you can teach
adults no matter any age to do this very
effectively but whether or not the
training ends up being a success depends
on how you do it and that's gonna be the
theme of The Talk today how should you
train your colleagues to adopt our
python or any code language
to do what they're formally doing in SAS
Excel or on their own
now for a lot of those 10 years I spent
training people as teaching workshops
I'm going to try to convince you today
that workshops standard training of all
varieties really is not an effective way
to re retrain or retool a Workforce to
use code
it's also true with online courses but
I'm going to show you how you have
options Beyond these things to do a very
good job of it
so how do you train a data scientist
first off
I want to start with my story when I
joined our studio 10 years ago it was a
very different world a lot of people
didn't know about r or if they did they
had these impressions of our that were
not very complementary so we had to
spread the word about R and we decided
to do that by teaching people to use R
in the Tidy verse which we are creating
at workshops
we also experimented with other partners
to do video courses online courses moocs
if there's a way to teach data science I
have done that and if you think of
someone who teaches data science there's
a good chance I might even worked with
them to help them do that as a
partnership
and
the reason there's nothing on this slide
right now is because I want to talk
about some of the negative experiences
and I don't want to associate that they
want in particular but what I quickly
noticed teaching data science was that
teachers out there really aren't that
good the workshops you see at
conferences they're not so great and
even some of the online courses I really
question like how effective they would
be and after thinking about this I
realized you know the people who become
experts at coding or data science did
that by devoting years of their life to
becoming that expert but they didn't
have a chance to devote those years to
being a good teacher either or even find
out what made teaching work
serendipitously my background is in
Psychology I have a PhD in statistics
but that's from doing psychological
research relies on statistics I work
maybe over to writing code that supports
statistics and now what we call data
science in the background in Psychology
alerted me to the fact that there's many
things that you can do to make training
more successful and I thought well you
know there's there's these theories are
well established like cognitive load
Theory multimedia learning theory all
the rest they all apply to learning and
if we apply these to the data science
training environment we should be able
to make a much better Workshop
if there are any trainers in the
audience I strongly recommend learning
about these things and there is a book
that makes it really simple to learn
about the research all the most
important educational research is
covered in this book here it's called
how learning happens by Paul kirschner
and Carl Hendrick so that's something
you might consider if you're developing
your own training programs
anyways I took this and I put it into my
workshops and my training programs and
it worked amazingly people love the
workshops that I was creating I started
to win Awards like crazy on here's a and
it corresponds that sent me from the the
American statistical Association because
I'd come to teach at their JSM
conferences and they they pulled all the
students their statisticians and the
workshop that was highest rate amongst
many many workshops would always win an
award the Excellence in continuing
educational work well I won it three
years in a row and that was
unprecedented and and then because of
that they hired me to go around the
country and teach at different chapters
including Hawaii so I got to go to
Hawaii as a teacher it's a picture of me
chat lagged over their teaching students
gave me La that's pretty cool uh but I
thought wow this is great I've cracked
the code I could teach a really
effective Workshop these students are
telling me in every Workshop that
learning R is going to be life-changing
for them because they could see how
it'll be so much easier to do things
they're doing and they'll actually be
able to do more it'll be like a phase
shift because they have the
reproducibility and executability of
their code
so I thought the world looks pretty good
but
I still have a background in Psychology
and I started exploring the educational
psychology the education the literature
of psychology that's related to
education and there are some disturbing
signals in there I'll share some of
those with you
for example
the the best we could tell based on
Research is that students only remember
about 56 percent it's about half of the
content that you tell them in a lecture
and that's what if you if you test them
immediately after the lecture and we
expect that this drops off from there as
time goes by there's this study where
I'm getting this number from
but this is sometimes very disturbing if
you're a trainer not only is this
disturbing the students are being tested
here are undergraduates at College who
we might think of as professional
Learners if they can only manage to
remember half of what they learned in a
lecture then a distracted adult less go
right back to all their other work
responsibilities probably go learn even
less
that's not very good
next other studies uh here's to say that
looks at
procedural instructions so this is more
like teaching someone how to do a
procedure whether that's using a machine
or or fitting a certain model or you're
something that you do it's a behavior so
it's not like something you take a test
on later and they find same numbers
immediately after the training where the
students are doing the thing only 60 of
them can can reproduce it
and then six months later that drops a
forty percent one year later that drops
to 30 percent
and so on
so that's not great either and most
trainers I discovered weren't aware of
this at all but you can look at the
students being trained and kind of get
the sense that this is exactly what is
happening
I went back to my workshops and I
continued to teach and I continue to get
rave reviews and I realized what all the
knobs were to make student satisfaction
really high in a workshop but I also
realized
They Don't Really relate to the
stickiness of what the student's
learning and anecdotally I started to
check back in on some of my students and
I realized even though they love the
workshop and they could do lots of great
things in the workshop
they weren't doing those things a year
later or six months later
to me that seems like a training failure
and I
I'm not going to speak for everyone but
I almost feel like it's a dirty secret
of the training industry that
don't get terrific outcomes as a trainer
I've heard people talk about marketing
and say you know we know half of what we
do works we just don't know which half
well it seems like that might be the
case for training as well
but we were dealing with a field where
people aren't trained to be trainers so
I think there's lots of upside to do
much much better and that's what we set
out to do at our studio which is now
positive
and the way we fix this is by looking
into why this happens so some of you may
have seen this this graph before it's
called the forgetting curves or the
ebbing house curves based on the
gentleman who first postulated
this summarizes a body of research it
goes all the way back to the 1800s it's
been
verified in many different fields it's
just a fact of human life and the way to
look at the graph is these blue lines
are someone's ability to do something
be that to do a task
to remember vocabulary
to take a test it's just their ability
to do that thing that they learned in
the first Blue Line shows how that
ability changes over time
depending on the ability and what the
train is like it it drops off at
different rates so there's no units on
that axis this is more of a model here
but what happens consistently is your
ability to do something drops off after
you first learn it especially if you
never use it again your brain basically
cannibalizes the resources that devote
to that ability and uses them to do
other more important things you know and
eventually you can't do that thing
anymore
but you don't have to settle for that
outcome if you wait until that thing
starts to get difficult for you and then
you practice it and do it again you're
essentially relearning it through your
practice and you do it again and you
jump up to the next Blue Line so your
ability started to fall off but you
practice and now you can do it again
pretty well and then it starts to fall
off again
but it doesn't fall off as fast as it
did the first time if you had never
practiced it and if you repeat this
process and you practice again you'll be
on the next Blue Line and then the next
Blue Line
whenever you don't use something your
brain does start to lose its ability to
do it but the more you practice the
thing the more your brain decides to
conserve those neural networks and
retain that ability now if you've
practiced something enough times you've
learned to ride the bike and it stays
with you forever
you could sort of see
why this doesn't play out in a workshop
that you
take for half a day or two days or what
have you and then you never really see
it again
these these practice sessions work
because your brain is building new
neural circuitry in between that means
you have to go to sleep nighttime sleep
in between these sessions to really
build up a robust neural network
I have occasionally had people sleep in
my workshops but I don't think that was
causing the effect we'd look for here
I'm also realizing I could have used
these slides to explain this a little
more clearly but this is what I just
said how the more you practice the more
it changes the trajectory of forgetting
until eventually you don't really forget
all right so we could see in the data
that's how that works but we also know
from research and study why it happens
this is your brain it's a collection of
neurons that are joined together and
your abilities and the information you
know and the memories you have are all
encoded into your brain as networks
between these neurons
the network is set up so in one neuron
in the network fires the other
neuronspire as well they trigger
whatever Behavior needs to come together
to make this experience that your brain
is recreating for you
and we can imagine having two networks
that do two separate things in our brain
one of these we use every time we use it
those neurons fire together and then
your brain wires them together a little
more strongly because this is how the
brain works you've probably heard
neurons that fire together wire together
every time you use it that Network it's
stronger and stronger whereas the one
you don't use gets weaker and weaker
your brain has important things to do
it's not going to maintain a network
that doesn't do anything useful until
eventually over time you will have a
very very strong Network at the thing
you were doing
so strong that doing it no longer takes
conscious thought it's completely
automated when one of the neurons in the
network fires due to some cue or trigger
all the rest just automatically Cascade
and you juggle the ball or fit the model
or interpret the data
whereas that other neural network that
we never use it doesn't even exist
anymore it's gone
right so this this is the biological
phenomenon that explains the forgetting
curves and like I said this wiring
together occurs while you're sleeping so
this is something that happens with lots
of repetition over a long period of time
weeks let's say
if we go back to our model and think
about do we want our colleague to be
able to do this new skill pick a skill
where the answer is yes and then
consider what is going to determine
whether or not he or she could do that
six months from now
you'll discover it's very little to do
with the initial instruction we give the
colleague and everything to do with the
amount of practice they've had shortly
after that instruction
so how do we train to take advantage of
this how do we train to make people who
can use ours well as SAS six months from
now
foreign
something else to consider as well
just watching a lecture or watching a
video on your computer about doing
something
probably builds a neural network but
it's a neural network that's related to
sitting still and watching a video
unfold
it's actually doing the thing that
builds a neural network so you'll later
used to do the thing so we have to be
conscious of that and train too and
unfortunately a lot of training doesn't
really focus on the student actually
doing the things that's more hey watch
this video
maybe there's a multiple choice question
afterwards maybe there's not
so what does this mean for us well the
revelation we added our studio is that
data science is a skill and if you want
to learn to do good data science with
code or otherwise you have to practice
it and learn it as a skill and a great
analogy would be playing the piano or
some musical instrument those are skills
as well there are things you need to
learn like you know how to read notation
Rhythm music
but you also need to practice a piano if
you want to play a song on the piano and
you wouldn't expect to do this well by
watching
an online course or videos online
I mean maybe I could supplement what you
are going to do to learn to play the
piano
you wouldn't expect to learn to play the
piano well either by attending the short
Workshop that lasts for a day or two
days
I mean my health it might get you
enthusiastic to do the practice you need
afterwards
but then if you want to play the piano
you do need to practice over time and
usually with some sort of feedback
from an expert who's mentoring you as
you play the piano and the same is true
for data science we need to use practice
over time to learn to do it in a new way
all right so what about online courses I
mean they can last over time right
well
what we find or what you would find too
if you research the training communities
students don't complete online courses
they don't stay very engaged with them
even when they do complete them
and at being someone who's designed many
online courses I can tell you it's very
hard to design an online course that
multiple students can come to and be
challenged by without a teacher they're
overseeing the process
you sort of have to design for the
lowest common denominator and that's not
enough to help the rest of the class
learn
when we look at really well supported
massive online courses like the Johns
Hopkins or Coursera moocs
you see that's typical for you know
about 10 students to finish those
we've also had the the privilege in my
life to look at the data for some online
data science training providers because
they're partnering with them and what we
saw was something that's very similar to
a gym lots of people pay for the
subscription to go to the gym but the
other day they never show up and go to
the gym they're just sort of paying it's
great if you're a gym collecting money
but it's not great if if you're paying
to get student outcomes because the
students don't go there and engage they
don't change
and the missing element for these online
courses whether it's a mooc or this gym
model is motivation
so
lots of people think Education Works
this way there's an educator they have
the information that the student needs
there's a student you just need to
transfer that information over
and then the students you know
thank you
now an expert
but that's not how Education Works at
all
information is cheap and easy and you
could get it from the library or YouTube
or wherever you want it but if you want
to learn to use that information you
have to do something after you acquire
it and this is the hardest part of
learning something it's you have to
practice it in a loop over and over
again and it's easy to start practicing
things the wrong way and as a student
you might not even know you're doing it
and then you're just building neural
networks that encode mistakes it's not
going to work out well you need to
practice and get feedback
maybe some coaching the practice itself
is hard work and all of that work
requires you to be motivated
it's hard for busy adults to stay
motivated at one more form of busyness
but this blue loop here is what matters
if we want our colleagues to become
excellent our users or python users or
data scientists
most training environments ignore the
blue loop that happens after the
training's over
so what we decided to do is focus on
that Bluetooth to make it easy to do the
hard work
of learning to do it as efficiently as
possible so you know it's paying off and
they give you the coaching that keeps
that practice Loop where it should be so
you're practicing the right things
instead of spinning off into mistakes
so what does that look like how do
humans actually learn skills
might seem like the training industry is
botched and if you want to help your
people transition over to R go have a
hard time of it but it's not actually
the case we learn skills every day in
modalities that are very familiar and
that lots of people have confidence in
so we use pianos as a metaphor earlier
if you want to learn to play the piano
you would find a piano coach or a music
teacher then give you some one-on-one
feedback and it'd be a process
but every apprenticeship also works this
way every internship every residency
if the thing you're trying to learn
happens to be a physical skill we call
it coaching these things work all the
time
we need an experience like this for
using R for doing data science
so how should your analysts learn data
science or code raw or python
we've put together an experience that
looks like this and this is my answer
this is how it should look
if you train with ours with posit
Academy the first thing you have is a
mentor a mentor is someone who knows how
to do data science with r and they're
going to help you they're going to coach
you to learn it
we have two types of Mentor at academy
one is the type that we provide we
provide experts to help people learn and
the other type is a mentor that the
company who engages us provides they act
as an apprentice in the course
experience an apprentice Mentor but
they're another resource for students
and the cool thing about Apprentice
mentors from the company is
after the experience is over that
Apprentice is still at the company still
acting as a mentor still forming the
node of a support network within the
company so you build up a community of
practice let me talk more about that man
the next thing you have in addition to
your mentor
group mates
we've designed a cohort based learning
experience where no one learns in
isolation they learn in small groups of
five to seven students who are all
trying to learn the same thing as you
are
so as you go through the course not only
do you have an export expert who has
your back who's coaching you you also
have fellow Travelers who you could
discuss things with you could work
through problems together and you may
not even realize it but you can hold
each other accountable and motivated as
you go through the process
so those are the people involved next we
give you a project to do so an academy
course is not in a course it's an
apprenticeship you're going to do
something very real and very close to
what you do at your job because that's
ultimately what you want to learn how to
do we want you to see the value of
everything you're learning and the best
way to do that is to make it similar to
your work which is very valuable to you
so an example project would be comparing
different treatments maybe with asthma
maybe with some sort of disease if you
came to us from Finance we give you a
finance project and whatnot but we we
give you something that is close to what
you're going to do
and you're going to do it under the
guidance of the mentor and with the
support of your groupmates
each project is scoped to cover what we
think or we have found over the past
decade is essential to learning R so
that begins with importing data
exploring the data with plots and
visualizations
wrangling your data
analyzing it if you're familiar with r
I'm talking about D ply or Thai Dr joins
that sort of thing but also fitting
models to your data
and then how do you summarize your work
to communicate with someone else and how
do you do that reproducibly so the next
time you have a similar project you're
already way ahead and you start with
your previous work versus making it up
from scratch
we focus on our markdown and now
increasingly chordo which is the next
version of our markdown
so you're going to do all of that to
complete your project
and do that real life thing that you
will presumably now be able to do at
your job and create a lot of value with
but how do we make that happen it can't
happen off thin air
we break the project into 10 Progressive
Milestones each week you work on one of
these Milestones when you get to the
tenth one you finish the project you
have your portfolio piece which is a
report that shows the conclusion of all
your data science work
but each of those Milestones build up to
that in sequence so first you learn the
basics of working with r how does
troubleshoot what to do if you get stuck
and you need help or what to do if you
hear the new package or a new function
and you want to teach yourself how to
use it we teach you how to teach
yourself that's a big part of working
with r
then you learn visualization then you
learn data wrangling and joints and so
on
you could think of the project
as
the skeleton or the backbone of the
course so most course have a syllabus we
have a project and it functions a little
bit like a syllabus you're going to need
to do all these real life things
to finish the project
you divide into our milestones
and then we prepare tutorials that teach
you what you need to do to do that
Milestone so if you have to fit a model
in R and you're just learning R you
don't know how to do that we're going to
assign you tutorials from the library
tutorials we've written that will show
you how to fit models in R these
tutorials are designed to teach through
exercises we've written grading code
they give us a type of artificial
intelligence that will look at the code
you submit and if it's wrong they'll
give you advice on how to fix that code
it doesn't focus on unit tests or making
sure your result is right it looks at
what you're writing and tells you how to
change that because that's what you need
to learn
and then at the end of that week after
you've learned your tutorials done your
Milestone we have you get together with
your group and present what you've done
we ask you for each Milestone to
recreate something a step in your
project if you've saved the tutorials
you should be able to do that Recreation
but then we ask you to teach yourself
something new
to create a personalized or extended
Milestone that you could present to your
groupmates
this creates a lot of cross-pollination
when the group mates get together they
learn from each other but it also helps
you practice teaching yourself new parts
of an ever-expanding free and open
source language like r
the group sessions
we hold them over Zoom or Microsoft
teams look something like this
these are some of our former illustrious
clients you share your screen you you're
going to be working with the r Studio
IDE which is a real tool made day
scientists use
this is what's in posit workbench you
also end up working with posit connect
so you you learn how to use the real
tools that you can start using the day
after Academy ends in fact most students
start using them well before Academy and
set their work to create value
foreign
give you the accountability you have to
show up with something to show them you
also meet with them during the week one
time for a co-working session to work
through the trouble together
but they're more than just the people
who make sure you did your assignment
after the course is over there your
future support network the the
beginnings of a community of practice
that you've established by learning all
or inside your pharmaceutical company
all right so typically do some tutorials
complete and personalize a milestone
presented to the group
in between you have a co-working session
with your group mates to help out it's
optional but we strongly encourage
people to go and most people do go and
then you have a communication Channel
like slack or Microsoft teams where you
can discuss the project and answer each
other's questions and your mentors there
too to answer questions your Mentor is
also at each of the in-person sessions
repeat this until you finish your
project
and that's what the academy experience
looks like
so does this work can this teach someone
who doesn't know R to use R and do real
data science with it
the answer is yes we've taught about 600
students so far using this method we
have about 95 completion rate this is
for a course that lasts 10 weeks 12
weeks normally because we put in some
breaks for holidays and stuff just based
on how the year works out and the
students stick with it
here's an example student Keith wickel
from Kellogg Company I'm calling him out
as an example because he posted on
LinkedIn in public
but
what we see with other students is
something what we see with Keith people
are really excited to be students in
this sort of experience
they're really excited to actually
Apprentice on something learn it well
and have a mentor there to help them
through any question that comes up any
challenge that they have or anything
they want to explore that we didn't put
in the course but they know their
interest in they can do it and discuss
it with their mentor and groupmates
so our students like it but we're our
customers are actually companies we're
trying to help companies create capacity
to do work that didn't exist previously
in their company
it works there too this is probably the
most on the nose quote from a previous
customer the James Wade showed us at a
previous R Studio Enterprise media I
guess now there might be positive
Enterprise meetups and he said
they were very interested in where this
is working as we went back and they
surveyed the students they put through
Academy six months after they left
Academy they found that 16 out of the 17
students were still writing code at
least once per month or more frequently
using what they learned in academy
and that 17th person by the way was
promoted to a manager so they no longer
had the right code but they were
convincing their direct reports to start
using R and write code based on the
academy
now
I don't know how you feel about that
because you're not a trainer but perhaps
based on what you saw at the beginning
of my talk that this is unheard of in
the training Community 16 out of 17
survey response but it's not unheard of
out of our customers this is par for the
course but James went on record about it
we have taught pharmaceutical companies
uh there's there's a quote on our
our website posit.com Academy
where AstraZeneca talks about how great
their Academy experience was it's more
General language I'm a data scientist so
I chose this quote with Theta
but it works people notice the
difference and they sign back up for for
more cohorts of more students
anyways thank you for listening to me I
you may have noticed I'm not pharmacist
I'm an educator and and I geeked out on
education but I hope after hearing this
you get a sense of what you need to do
to successfully transition your
colleagues to r or to python from
wherever they're coming from these
principles work in every circumstance
and if you avoid them
you're going to have fleeting gains at
best
so thank you everyone I'll stop screen
sharing now
thank you so much Garrett um I'll pull
your screen
backstage here I see a few questions
um coming in now but I also thought it
might be helpful I know you were gonna
maybe pull up
um Academy and show one of the examples
in there too I thought it might help for
a frame of reference for some of the um
the questions too
sure shall we start there sure that
would be great
I will
share my screen again
all right if you want to just make that
one full screen and then pull it over
there we go
like that yep I can see
so this is the student landing page or
an example student landing page
for the Academy experience now remember
so much of the experience is about that
social motivation you get from your
group and your mentor and talking to
them outside of this this platform here
but when it comes time to do your
learning in a tutorial this is where you
go we have a syllabus on the side that's
divided into different Milestones you
can see first we're just learning R then
we're importing and visualizing our data
adding variables and these things are
progressive they build on each other
until eventually you're
fitting models and writing your own
reports and Publishing them
within each week we have the lessons
that you take and then the Milestone
that you do
if you go into the Milestone file takes
a ferment to open up but uh
it's opening up the r Studio IDE
we provision the IDE with the different
files that you would need or that you
might find at your job if you're doing
this type of task
and we have an R markdown document that
guides you through the task
so this is the first Milestone it's it's
kind of like a hello world in some ways
but we gave you some data we want you to
open up once you look at it we want you
to recreate something in this case
give them an image of a plot and say
there's a function that does this it's
the hist function we did not tell you
about it this week but we did tell you
how to read help pages and learn about
functions so can you learn about this
function and make this plot
and then we give them an extension which
is okay let's push this a little further
maybe you could change the color maybe
you could scour that help page and learn
about your options and try to apply to
them
this is the first Milestone they get
more and more advanced as you become
more comfortable with r
the uh
yeah I was gonna jump over to a few of
the questions too and we can mix it in
and maybe show through Academy here but
I see
um Ben had asked thanks Ben for the
question over on YouTube At what point
in the process would the ability to
creatively solve problems be expected
curious where the complexity of practice
should be introduced
that's a good question we don't
discourage creativity creativity for
solving problems at any point as as the
Milestones get more complicated
they sort of become more Divergent so in
the second week already you'll be making
plots and
each project is Guided by a motivating
question which might be as simple as you
know is there a difference between these
two treatments or might be you know what
factors predict this thing
and normally within those questions
there's multiple relationships you might
search for to discover especially if
it's what factors cause this
who knows so you we encourage the
students
to go to be curious explores many
relationships and data maybe you can
make their own new variables or features
to explore and visualize with different
types of plots
even when you're comparing treatment
groups you might want to look for
differences Beyond you know the outcome
of that disease there might be
meaningful differences in like blood
pressure or things that that we'd want
to know about so I would say as soon as
the second week there's there's lots of
room for experimentation exploration
reporting new things back also that that
extension piece allows people
to to really learn a lot of different
things for example I've had a student
who thought
uh I like the plot I made but this would
look really interesting animated because
there's something over time
ours free it's all free it's all very
accessible online so he went out and
taught himself the GG anime package and
brought that back he was able to do that
because we talked about how to learn new
packages
so I would like to say that this is
built into the process
now what's
what happens that isn't Apparent from
anything I could show you here is the
students come into a session and they're
talking about
and doing an anova or whatnot and maybe
the day is heavily censored right
and they have a mentor and normally a
Company Mentor as well
and every all the ingredients are there
to have a discussion about what is the
best practices for this type of data
like how do I go about solving this
problem thinking about this problem from
The Apprentice Mentor or the mentor side
uh
a relationship develops within the group
that goes to the places where the group
or the mentors think is useful
thank you
um something else I wanted to to make
sure that we cover I mean especially
given the given the title too but I know
you have an
um an awesome example in the academy
project Gallery
um that covers uh modification of diet
and renal disease I thought that might
be a great example to share
I mean
see my screen right I can't see it yet I
hit it uh hit it backstage but I did I
actually just grabbed the link for you
too so that you had it in the private
chat
okay well I could oh yeah I could say it
okay let me pull it over there we are
so we when a new customer comes and
talks to Academy we try to find the
project that fits best with them and we
have
many projects that already exist and
um
we've developed a consultation with
clients on one of them is No actually
that's the wrong one but
you had a specific one and that was
I thought because it's focusing more on
there right there yeah
modification of diet and renal disease
so this
sometimes we have to be clever about
getting around HIPAA and regulations and
stuff so this is data that's actually
been published in scientific literature
so it's it's
not getting in trouble for using it and
it is a clinical trial that
I looked at four different treatment
groups on on renal disease so kidney
disease and the treatment groups vary
the level of
blood pressure medication the patients
took and also the amount of protein in
their diet so we had we had four
different groups
and who ultimately we run an anova to
determine
whether or not
there's a difference between the groups
these are the the 10 milestones in the
project so first they're go create a
histogram of the the measure that we're
interested in how
how much your kidneys can filter
the measure of Kidney Health
um we we progressively get them from
using base R so so first we just want to
make sure they could use our functions
then we start teaching packages like
Gigi plot2 that's the graphics package
in our
and they group and summarize by patient
to reveal things that you wouldn't find
in the data as it is but you can derive
from the data We join in a second data
set that they can work with
retiree and pivot tables
we um
start reporting our results in a way
that makes it useful to turn in
assignments but also to turn in reports
or decisions to people that your team is
working for
we work with different types of data
such as strings
dates times depends on you know what's
sort of data
you would work with that work that's
what you work on on your project but we
do teach you how to work with these type
of data in the tutorials
and then here we have some Divergence
between fitting models and writing
functions
um
on some data
here's some of the artifacts students
make over the course of 10 weeks on this
project
the way this project looks to the
students though this is sort of an
executive summary that I could share
with my colleagues what the students see
is what I was showing on positive
Academy so this is the actual mdrd
project
so
um
if we get to Milestone six
mdrd stands for modification diet and
renal disease you see we're talking
about
globular filtration rate so this is the
project
and they in week six they get this
Milestone so run the code below to make
the table
this is not the code you'd write to make
the table it's just code that delivers
off the table we made so now they have
to figure out how to take their data set
which they're very familiar with and fit
a model
that returns this table here and they
can check to see if they did it right if
it looks the same
and uh
then they can extend that changing maybe
the variables in the model or whatnot
thank you for walking through that I see
a lot of questions that are coming
through from both slido and on YouTube
so I'm going to pull one over from slido
here and I can hide the screen so that
you can see it on
there as well but one was can you share
more details on how Academy was
structured for customers and Life
Sciences or are there any measures of
student engagement and overall success
in life science
yes
so first of all Academy is not
structured specifically for Life
Sciences it's structured specifically
for people who need to learn r or python
to do what they do
we've we've become experts in teaching R
in Python
and what we found is it's not very
different whether you need to use R to
do this or to do that it's not even that
different if you're coming from SAS or
Excel if if you're coming from SAS we
can use the knowledge you have about SAS
as a springboard to connect to R but at
the end of the day
we're not going to give you a
translation guide that shows you how you
know task where the bathroom is and are
we want to teach you to teach to speak
fluently in R and that's what we
achieved in 10 weeks so our our
structure looks the same for Life
Sciences as for other Industries you
need to know
how the the mental models of the r
language so it's divided into functions
and objects and this is what those mean
you need to know where to get your help
from whether or not you're going to use
clinical trials data or pre-clinical
trials data the r language operates the
same way you need to know the tools that
execute your code you need to know
procedures for backing out of something
that didn't work and finding the right
path forward
and then there's a lot with Theta that
is also remarkably similar across
different fields so we make sure you
know how to get your data into R where
you could use it if you have really big
data we'll teach you how to get R to the
data in a database using the DP player
package if
once you have your data you need to know
how to join tables together R works best
when you put everything in one table
before you analyze that we teach you
that and that's field independent
tidying your data or works best if your
data is in rectangular format or tidy
data format we teach you that
how you make a plot is the same there's
so many commonalities
across the industries that
that really there's just one and a half
or so weeks that are different from task
to task at this level and that's what
the projects capture so perhaps that's
what I should be talking towards
each project
teaches the scope of all those things
it's the scope of what you'd find inside
the book are for data science by the way
but it takes the payoff step what I call
the payoff step the model that's
valuable to you with the type of data
you use and the tweaks that are
idiosyncratic to the type of data you
use and it matches those to your
industry
so how do we structure things for Life
Sciences we made projects that looked at
data that life scientists or life
science industries use and that ask
questions and answered the questions
that life scientists ask an answer of
that data
we don't train anyone to be a life
scientist
you train them to be like scientists who
uses R but we assume we're meeting them
as life scientists already now we just
show what how to use R to do the things
that they're interested in
thank you so much Garrett and I know we
had Devin backstage kind of helping with
some of the the questions in the chat
too so I I wanted to pull you on here as
well Devin because I know you work with
so closely with many of our life
sciences life science customers as well
I just want to see if you had anything
to add to that too
yeah thanks Rachel can everyone hear me
okay yeah you sound great awesome
um
I think part of the flavor that I can
add that Garrett really hit home
throughout the entire webinar is that
um to frame Academy against some of the
leading questions that you'll often see
is that groups are coming with very
differentiated needs you know even in
very specific areas like just clinical
programming right for some groups it's
we have this large set of SAS
programmers and we're trying to convert
them to R for other groups uh uh they're
trying to do novel analytics that
they've never done before so they're
coming from like a clean slate
um but ultimately a lot of the patterns
across companies across groups
um are still consistent uh and so part
of the beauty of Academy is bridging a
lot of the pedagogical techniques but
recognizing the fact that the more
domain specific they become the more
they're going to immediately resonate
and so I think you know with respect to
like the analog realizing clinical trial
data elements this is absolutely a call
to say that you know we have been
engaging with companies interested to do
that looking to
develop a program that fits what type of
work that they are trying to do but it
is a conversation to have it is not a
um kind of a routine hey everyone is
going to go through these same motions
and hopefully they'll come with the same
outcome instead it really is about
saying what is your group trying to do
we understand and we can speak towards
some of the high level objectives that
most groups are coming into it we know
you're going to need to generate certain
types of tables and figures and legends
um or expect to do particular types of
analyzes But ultimately trying to teach
that highly specifically is still not
going to position a group to be able to
take the learnings from Academy and
extend it to all the scenarios they want
so so just infused throughout the entire
program is that uh desire to both
Empower people to like think in terms of
how they're trying to approach their
analytics and give a lot of those
pedagogical techniques like repetition
to make sure that
um you're able to successfully on-ramp
uh to the language and I think that's
one of the observations that in kind of
my last decade or so of interacting with
groups is even if they crack open a book
or they crack crack open some courses
when they start to work uh on their own
projects that they can't you know copy
and paste some code snippet to work off
of it's easy to get Frozen as soon as
something doesn't work and you don't
really know where to go and groups that
go through Academy we see things like
they're enabled and empowered to be able
to troubleshoot to diagnose and to kind
of move off of the path that was covered
uh even within the given context and so
um that's why we really look forward to
being able to continue to extend
um those teaching engagements and really
are looking for people to to Broach what
are they interested to learn and and the
answer in most cases is not going to be
like no we won't teach that it is a
conversation about how are you trying to
uh to empower the group and what so I
think there are some of the questions of
like you know will you teach a you know
doing co-works analysis or certain
regression like that is uh those are the
questions that we're looking to start
that dialogue with as part of this
webinar and into the future and so I
don't I don't know if there are any that
um that would bubble up at the moment
but if not I think that's the kind of
question that we're looking to engage
with groups to learn more about their
specific needs and figure out how to
make them successful
thank you Devin
and I see a comment in the the chats
Stephen had mentioned I really like the
learning curve slide and would like to
reuse that and ask if some of this would
be available so I wanted to make sure I
shared on the screen here that you can
access the slides at this short link we
can re-share that in the chat as well
but with that question asked I was just
curious for people that are joining us
here today
are you kind of in charge of training
some of the New Year's users across your
team or do are you part of a data
science Community within your company as
well
um if you want to put into the chat I
just I just love to learn from
you all there too
but an academy specific question that I
see from YouTube uh Garrett is how are
the groupmates paired are they assembled
by similar levels
we've experimented with this and what we
what we do right now is we pair
groupmates based on similar objectives
like the task to be done are they going
to do similar tasks and what that means
is you could have some really Advanced
star users who maybe they've been using
R quite a bit but not really the Tidy
verse or maybe not for the task to go do
with brand new beginners and that works
quite well
having everyone the same works as well
too they both work well but what's
interesting is when you have people from
different levels
the ones who are more experienced act as
sort of mentors because you're putting
them together in this team group
experience and any teacher will tell you
that's a more effective way to learn
than learning and teaching is is a great
way to learn and they're there in their
teaching and the uh
since since the Recreations are we feel
they're doable for beginning students no
one feels like they fall far behind but
the extensions they can run as as far
and as fast as they want to so those who
are ready for more of a challenge can
push themselves the mentors there to
help them no matter what stage they
start to get bogged down and those who
are are beginners Well they push
themselves too and it just so happens
they get bugged down here but the mentor
is there to help them too uh it it's
we've had lots of success mixing levels
that uh
that again is another observation from
interacting with a lot of these groups
both within Academy and you know not
with Academy doing workshops is that
um there's often a perception from a lot
of folks in the Pharma sphere that like
um
that the data science activities are
like a small component of their job
maybe they need to also be considering
around how decision making is performed
um uh other more domain-specific
activities But ultimately a lot of their
day-to-day is still spent
in our doing work and so even if you
have been exposed to R for a while and
you might be you know an intermediate
even pushing into advanced there's still
a lot of
um
a lot of value in kind of
re-establishing those fundamentals in a
way that you probably like had to learn
on the fly on the job where some of the
activities that you used to say like
well I know the Motions to fix this I
don't exactly know why but I kind of
waved my hands for a bit and then
eventually it works like all of a sudden
a lot of those uh Concepts suddenly
become clear and become kind of
emphasized and covered over and over so
we do see even with those intermediate
users going in even though the content
itself is something that they can
approach they really are able to take
off and be much more efficient with
their time especially if they're coming
in and out where they might have to set
aside R for a bit to do other business
activities and they come back where you
know those routine kind of memorized
motions easily fall away but as you
establish those foundational kind of
mental models they stick for a lot
longer and so you know if you are like
that kind of intermediate user thinking
is Academy how would I use this like
there is something to be said for those
intermediate or those power users where
you bridge those fundamentals in and you
can even use that to help train people
within your organization as you yourself
sharpen your mental models it makes you
a more effective kind of Mentor an
enabler throughout your organization
thank you I'm noticing there are a lot
of anonymous questions over on on slido
and one of them was
do you do or can you do a shiny course
thank you for whoever asked
that I hope it wasn't my boss we are
developing a shiny course it's still in
production but it's not ready yet
it will be soon maybe by the end of the
year
sounds great
um and then we touched upon this a
little bit in talking about uh different
customers we worked with but how
specific can projects get
the the projects are all very similar in
that there's a data set you're going to
visualize it you go wranglate you're
going to report on it you're going to
fit a model to it
what's in the data set can be anything
it's up to you like as long as it has
several variables and it's nice if one's
continuous and maybe one's you know
discrete and maybe there's a binary
variable but I think you have a sense of
what a
a rich data set would look like
and then if the modeling method that you
want to apply to it
maybe this is really what matters to or
ask the question
if it's something that you would cover
in a stats 101 course or even a 201
course we can go ahead and teach that
right now
we will eventually be developing a
course based on Tidy models and machine
learning where you go much deeper but
for the course we offered today we don't
teach the statistics for the machine
learning
unless it's something some low hanging
fruit like a stat 101 or 2-1 course
so time series sure uh survival analysis
yeah linear models Anova logistic
regression that's all that's all the
level we're teaching right now
oh thank you another question I was just
copying over from slido somebody had
asked how does this compare to platforms
like datacamp
foreign
ly uh we're really focused on that that
cohort interaction that human
interaction creating essentially a de
facto community of practice amongst the
students with their Mentor empowering
that to continue within the company
afterwards
the motivation and the engagement
from what I've seen is is night and day
different people are really motivated by
social pressures and also the identity
that they build by engaging in a group
that's learning data science
so I think data Camp is in platforms
like it are really great tools for
people who are enthusiastic and
motivated have time to spare self
Learners do there and I know people who
are like that I'm like that too
but I'm not like that when things get
busy or hectic or whatnot and what I see
is engagement does drop off if you don't
have that group of people
who are pushing you through that's what
we're trying to provide here so
I do think that
that you will notice the difference but
I I don't really feel that comfortable
talking about trick comparisons
thank you I
I'm seeing a few questions into the
YouTube chat right now as well I think
so a few of them are around like is this
only for
organizations or can individuals use
data
I mean sorry instead of using data cam
you can use Academy as well
yeah right now it's it's for
organizations we are expanding it to
individuals
not just yet but look this year for its
expand individuals or you know
groups of two or three even
Oliver throwing me off with some of
these anonymous questions here all right
let me uh let me jump back to
some of those Anonymous ones and sort
through
um
let's see
um and then just to confirm somebody had
asked I assume because you showed uh the
Dow example that this can be
Industries outside of life science but I
just wanted to make sure that we answer
that question here for the person who
asked
absolutely yes anyone who wants to use
our we can teach you
and thank you all for these questions
here I'm sorting through from YouTube
from some of the comments too
and then another question was just like
around the the scope of what we can
teach
with Academy what about a topic like
package building
that's great so Academy is young as you
might be sensing and we started with how
to do data science with r
tidy verse our markdown quarter that
sort of thing we have a roadmap that
we're fleshing out the next course is
going to be programming with our
and I should say we're doing everything
we're doing python in parallel so
everything I say here about R also
applies for python so that's the course
of raining right now how to work with
functions and program with r which also
will get in the package building that is
a prerequisite I feel for actually
learning shiny for learning tidy models
for learning points more advanced and
that's where we'll be going next so
today
I couldn't sign you up and start
teaching package building this afternoon
but if you are interested in learning
that maybe in Q2 or Q3 it'd be totally
appropriate to come talk to us and we'll
tell you what we could do
that's great thank you there's uh one
other question that I want to make sure
I got to as well
and
I'm not sure if I can pull it up on the
screen right this second but Leonardo
had asked
and it's posit Academy also interested
in organizing a sizable amount of
courses for people who do not start from
scratch
we are but
um
the market for people starting from
scratch is much larger there is a much
larger need for people for example than
using a different language like SAS
their whole time to do stuff and now
they need to do it all
we're serving that but that road map
that I laid out you see it does it will
get to machine learning it will get to
shiny it will get to more advanced
topics
every time I talk to someone I wish I
could just jump to what they wanted to
learn today but we're we're trying to do
the most good in in the most chunks as
we go so
okay I said one more question before the
top of the hour but I think this is an
important one to address and I see Devin
you just answered in the chat too but
Ramil asked are there elements of
building data pipelines and best
practices foundations for clinical
trials
Devin do you want to answer there's kind
of like two elements to it like to me
when I think of the conversations around
data pipelines we think of like the
orchestration components of like I have
a variety of things I have some raw data
it gets processed a bit you have some
derivative data that you're going to
then tabulate and visualize and do some
other modeling activities potentially
against
um you know Academy won't necessarily
cover like how to uh deploy that data
Pipeline with whatever orchestration
system you might use whether that be
like our studio connect or posit connect
or some other pipeline but inside the
pipeline the analysis activities the the
the managing and munging of the data the
visualization the tabulation those are
the Core Concepts that are covered with
that so you should be set up to be able
to think from like I have raw data I
have Insight objectives on the other end
like what are the pieces that need to
stack together to do that those are well
within Academies
thank you very much I I'm going to do a
double check here if you have a question
that you really want to make sure it's
answered if there's anything that I
missed if you want to put it into the
YouTube chat here again
um I did also mention in the beginning
uh when I was introducing the
presentation that we've recently had a
number of
great meetups and data science Hangouts
featuring different pharmaceutical
leaders and a lot of the questions from
those events have been targeted to
learning and how to teach groups of new
users who might be moving from SAS to to
R and my colleague Isabella recently put
together a great blog post that kind of
highlights
each of those different leaders
perspectives on moving to open source in
the Pharma space and so I just want to
put that in the chat there because they
thought it might be really helpful for
people listening in today
um
one question let's see I think if there
were some I know we're a little bit over
if if there are any other questions or
anything that you missed I'm going to
take some time that I miss I'm going to
take some time to go through all those
questions and I will get back to you
um if there's anything that's not
answered and you want to reach out to me
directly I'm also going to just
strengthen in the chat here for you all
as well always feel free to connect with
me I love to meet you all and always
happy to connect you with your teams
here at posit as well I'm sure many of
your
uh your companies are are working with
some of our customers success reps too
so
thank you all so much for joining Devin
and Garrett any last uh final words to
share
foreign
thank you very much everyone
thank you all so much have a great rest
of the day